in a season where so much of the nfl is
different the raiders
rivalry versus phillip rivers is alive
and well
john treach has more on this very
familiar matchup
old habits are hard to kick like the
raiders playing phillip rivers with the
season depending on it
the former chargers qb has 47 touchdown
passes
against the silver and black to his
resume he may be in a new uniform
but he's the same old gunslinger he has
more fun playing football than most guys
that i know
he has a passion about him that's rare
and uh
i know he wants to beat us in the worst
way he has a
disdain for the raiders he's made that
perfectly honest to me
you know something about playing raiders
twice a year it was a big deal uh you
know i kind of got first taste of it
with marty schottenheimer
you know out there in my first couple
years um you know so there's some
familiarity there obviously
even with groot being there the last
handful of years playing them twice
as an old soul it's fun for me to watch
because i respect the heck out of him
i think he's one of the best and anytime
you go against him you got to be ready
for a shootout you got to be ready
because
i've you know i've played against him
where it's come down to the wire i've
played against him where we've had the
lead and
you know here he comes you know coming
running back with it you know coming on
a
back good news for the raiders josh
jacobs was back at practice today
they're going to need everyone if
they're going to deny phillip rivers his
19th career victory
against the silver and black reporting
outside legion stadium
john treach